this video is sponsored by dashlane
conveniently store your passwords and
get 10
off premium when you sign up with the
link in the description
china is huge the kind of huge that's
hard to wrap your head around beginning
in the 1950s its population
exploded from an already respectable 500
million to almost three times that today
which makes it bigger than all of north
america australia
and europe combined its consistent
economic growth
has made it one of the world's great
powers with enough military might to
claim the strategically important
south china sea and enough influence to
begin the most ambitious
infrastructure project in history a one
trillion dollar network
of ports pipelines and railroads across
65 countries
but none of this was inevitable while
china rapidly and forcefully
industrialized it faced massive
famine and housing shortages its economy
needed time to develop
and the world deeply feared
overpopulation china's response was the
famous one-child policy
which limited ethnic chinese families to
a single child
with a few exceptions to enforce the law
women were forcefully sterilized and
fined for having too many children
the problem is it worked or something
did
historians doubt it prevented all 400
million births
claimed by the government but china's
total fertility rate the average number
of children
a woman will have in her lifetime has
fallen all the way to 1.6
well below the 2.1 needed to maintain
its size
there simply aren't enough children and
in a few short years
china will begin to shrink the one child
policy was repealed in 2015
but it won't make a significant
difference because it only ever sped
up the unavoidable as nations develop
they choose to have drastically fewer
children
china's problem isn't unique about half
the world
lives in a country that is or soon will
be in the same position
but it is uniquely big and the timing
uniquely bad the story of china in the
21st century
is just as much about demographics as it
is gdp
military power and the rule of xi
jinping
all of which will be seriously tested by
the coming demographic crisis
to understand why it's such a threat and
whether something can be done
we need to look a little more closely
as individuals humans are unpredictable
we don't know what someone will do or
say or buy
because they don't know impulse guides
your decision to add guacamole
just as it does what college you attend
but countries don't care about
individuals
they care about groups and the beauty of
demography
is that groups are predictable vary of
course
nothing is certain theories compete and
estimates vary
but it's much easier to guess how many
18 year olds will have in 30 years
and in general what they'll be doing
than say
the next three decades of foreign policy
or culture
no country has yet figured out how to
manufacture 18 year olds
not even china and that means population
today is a good peak at population
tomorrow when this information is
combined with geopolitics
or economics it goes from mildly
interesting
to downright powerful here's what we
know about
china each of these lines is one of its
age groups with babies at the bottom
and elderly at the top first are
consumers
from 18 to 45 we know people are
spending
they're going to school taking out loans
saving not so much and despite what this
group says about millennials
they're very important because consumer
spending is one of the biggest
contributors to economic growth
next are the money makers these people
have paid off their debt
now they're saving for retirement and
even though they're a smaller share of
the population
they generate most of its income in the
u.s for example
they alone pay half of all income tax
that makes them
a government's best friend finally at
age 65
people are done working done saving and
largely
done spending what's special about this
group is how quickly and how
dramatically
it begins in a single day a retiree
often goes from contributing the highest
taxes of their lifetime
to almost nothing as they slowly collect
pensions and social security
for right now let's ignore the total
number of people
china could be bigger like this or
smaller
like this what's important is the
balance between these different groups
and that's why this graphic is so useful
it's called
a population pyramid because for most of
history it has been
a constant stream of babies at the
bottom and a small number of deaths with
each subsequent year
a good example is niger where the
average woman has 6.5
children mortality is very high making
the average age
only 15 but much of the world no longer
looks like a pyramid
in china it's turning upside down as you
can see
there are two big bulges in its
population here
and here the first is currently in its
peak spending years
the second right in the prime of its
high earning high tax contributing years
it's no wonder china is seeing massive
economic growth
but that's what makes a demographic
crisis such an ugly one
it happens very slowly and then all at
once
remember this huge group of workers will
soon and quite suddenly retire
as they start waiting for the checks to
arrive but the group responsible
for writing those checks or at least
funding them is getting smaller
and smaller the problem isn't just
financial a single child must now care
for two parents and four
grandparents the united nations expects
china's dependency ratio
the number of non-working compared to
working age people
to increase at roughly the same rate as
japan's whose population began shrinking
in 2011
and now sells more adult diapers than
infant ones
by 2050 china may have more retirees
than all of germany japan
france and britain worse the one child
policy
combined with a cultural preference for
males has created a massive
gender imbalance as a result it's likely
that by 2030
one fourth of chinese men in their late
30s will have never married
at a minimum an abundance of forgotten
young men
will cause some social anxiety or
possibly as some experts suggest
serious conflict it sounds a lot like
the plot of a movie
perhaps no country for young men of
course china is aware of the problem but
it's fighting an inevitable demographic
transition in the beginning for china
the early 20th century
children are abundant because you can
only expect a few to survive
you don't have the education or tools
for family planning
and because the best way to grow
tomatoes is to first grow
children seriously for any
sleep-deprived parents watching this
will be a shock
but giving birth was once the ultimate
productivity hack
before there were tractors there were
children
and then people stopped dying it really
only takes a few
improvements to health care for rapid
reductions in mortality
and that's how the world grew from 1.6
to
6.1 billion people in one century
that short window where fewer people are
dying but everyone's still having
children
but it is just a window after mortality
drops
fertility is right behind it as
industrialization
brings rural workers to find jobs in the
city
children become less a utility and more
a liability
the kind that screams and cries and
generates student loan debt
the saying goes the best contraceptive
is economic development
the fact that countries like china the
us italy and germany have this problem
is an otherwise
good sign dangerously low fertility is
actually a side effect of many good
things
increased education opportunities for
women and health care
it's a no kidding first world problem
there are many ways to offset the damage
you can increase productivity taxes
immigration
and or fertility but it's hard to find a
solution that doesn't come with its own
set of problems
many countries for example now offer
incentives for having children
one of the most generous is sweden where
couples have the right to 480 days of
paid maternity leave
per child the downside employers are
more hesitant to hire young women who
are far more likely to take those days
off
and it doesn't help that even adjusted
for inflation the cost of raising a
child
has risen for decades babies just can't
compete with dogs
china has already gone from issuing
fines for second children to issuing
checks but people just don't seem to
want them
this paper predicts the new two-child
policy will only increase china's
population
from 1.4 to 1.45 billion in 2029
because a person's ideal family size is
largely determined by their own
two generations of chinese now see one
child
as the norm plus young people are
pressured to work
longer and harder to keep up with the
rising taxes
needed to support the older population
none of this means
china can't come up with a solution in
fact it has a few things going for it
as people move to the city they'll
become bigger contributors to the
economy
and today's young workers are far better
educated than those
they're replacing 11 years of schooling
compared to just
six there's also the bigger trend
towards an automation-based economy
which doesn't rely
on a large number of workers but that
too has the potential for chaos
and even if it does manage to increase
fertility
remember that demographic changes are
slow children born today
won't start contributing for at least 18
years
whatever the outcome it'll define
china's role in the 21st century
the one child policy will test china's
national security
just as your one password policy could
threaten
your security i know i know it's easy to
use the same password everywhere
but there's just no need to choose
between the convenience of a single
password and the security of many
with dashlane your passwords are kept
incredibly safe but without the hassle
you might expect the thing i love about
dashlane is that it takes care of
everything
the next time you log into a site it
remembers so you don't have to
and when you don't have to remember you
might as well make them as secure as
possible
if you want it to dashlane will log into
your accounts generate new passwords and
update them automatically and now is a
great time to sign up
they've added a vpn and a service which
scans the dark web to see if your
personal information
is being bought and sold by hackers
dashlane syncs between all your devices
and you can get started for free by
going to the link in the description
plus new users get 10 off premium
thanks to dashlane for sponsoring this
video and to you
for listening